So steps and healing you're gut, you got to change your diet.
You really have to change your diet.
So I think I got a slide on this.
So if you have a causative, some cause of inflammation that you're eating, you're never
going to heal your gut.
So we have patients that we test for gluten and it comes up positive.
And then I see them a couple of months later, how you do it on your gluten sensitivity.
Are you staying away from gluten?
Well, I'm pretty much like me and kind of pregnant, you know, you get it.
You know, you are either gluten free or you're not.
So there's been multiple studies done by actually one study that was done about a year
and a half ago and they gave patients that were gluten sensitive.
Literally, this is the study.
It sounds scientific.
A dime size piece of bread.
So they gave them, they measured the inflammation of their gut on the average.
There was an increase in inflammation for 10 weeks.
So you cannot be kind of gluten free.
If you have a food sensitivity, you have to stay off of that food.
Anything that's going to cause inflammation of the gut is further damaging the gut and
everything you're trying to do to help heal the gut is kind of self-defeating.
So just like Mike said, trying to run the right for this guy who's drinking a beer and
smoking a cigarette and both hands, it's really hard to heal somebody when you are causing
more damage than your ability to heal is there.
So you have to really decrease the sources of inflammation if you're going to get this person
better.
Does that make sense?
So food sensitivities stay away from genetically modified foods, trying to eat organic, trying
to eat more digestible fiber.
One of the studies that are out there, the best digestible fiber, if you're going to take
a fiber, is this modified gar gum that produces the most butarate.
There's a whole bunch of a list of different things that will help decrease inflammation of
the gut.
But really, we don't want to be addicted to taking a whole bunch of supplements that are
going to think that these supplements are going to heal us and people get in the habit of
this.
There's just a pill out there that I can start taking.
I'll take 10 pills.
If this is going to heal me, as long as I can still eat my donuts in the morning.
It just doesn't work that way.
You have got to decrease the sources of inflammation.
There's no way you could take enough corseted or marshmallow root to decrease the inflammation
that is going to be caused by that note that she's just ate.
So you have to be serious about that.
Many times, honestly, for years, I saw a lot of autoimmune patients.
That was really my specialty.
Now we see almost all about 70% cancer patients and maybe 30% lying patients.
One of the reasons I hate to say this, why I like those patients better, is that they'll
do what I say.
At least they'll do a better job at what I say, than a patient who's not quite so sick.
And I feel really lousy and I want you to get me better, but I don't really want to
change anything.
It's really difficult with that.
So first step is cleaning up your diet, cleaning up any inflammatory issues that is causing inflammation.
The second step is taking some prebiotics.
So a prebiotic would be taking modified gargum.
One company that makes that.
I have no connection with them as far as profit goes is a product that's called sun fiber.
That's the product that we use.
Sun fiber.
We're actually developing something, a product with them that's going to be out in about
a month, that's going to have some other things in the sun fiber that list here that I
think are really important.
So you have to develop a healthy mucus layer.
No understand, from a clinical perspective, you can measure these things.
So you can measure secretary IGA levels and see, get a pretty good idea, how much healthy
mucus this person has to be able to even support probiotics.
Thirdly, is to take a probiotic orally.
So you're taking a probiotic on a regular basis, what probiotics should you take?
Well, my opinion you want to take one with the highest amount of probiotics in them, and secondly,
you want to rotate brands.
I know supplement companies don't like it when I say that, but you have to rotate brands.
I've been in a lot of these nutritional companies, they grow their probiotics in what are called
hot rooms, and they're literally in these gigantic barrels with plastic line, and they're growing
the probiotics in there.
They skim them off every however long.
They dry them and capsulize them, so it's from the same mother batch.
So you want to switch brands and get some different brands of probiotics, so have one bottle
and for the finishes, change to another bottle, different brand.
There's so many good probiotics out there that you just want one with the highest concentration.
We use one that's a prescription one, it's called VSL, but that's a prescription one that
we use.
We use that a lot.
Yes, probiotic foods and beverages, let's talk about that right now.
So should I be eating probiotic foods and beverages?
Yes and no, so you have to be careful with that because if in our office, we like to run
some tests.
One of the labs that we like to use that I will push is a lab called Syrex lab.
So if you are going to a doctor right now, you can ask them about getting a Syrex lab done,
because you could do some tests, it'll test cross reactants, and one of the cross reactants
is yeast.
So if you have yeast issues and candida issues, then you have to be careful with the probiotic
foods.
You have to go slow, you can't introduce those right away.
You have to heal, they've got first, and then you can introduce those.
So probiotic foods are very good, what that is she's talking about, like water, kefir, and
kombucha, make your own kefir.
Those are great things that have a high concentration of probiotics in them, and fermented foods
like sauerkraut, but sometimes depending on the person's health and what they're dealing
with, you can't introduce those right away.
So there's some gut healing that you have to do before you introduce those, so that makes
sense?
So probiotics orally, that would include probiotic foods.
Patients that come to us, any time we have to do probiotics, rectally, so we do probiotic
animals, those are retention animals.
The bottom line is, when you have it in balance in your flora, and understand, your flora
is not solely in the gut.
You have flora in every cavity of your body.
That's why when you get a yeast infection because you have candida overgrowth, it can come
out in other areas of your body, not just your gut.
You don't even feel it in your gut, because the pain fibers that you have in your gut are solely
distension fibers.
So you don't feel any pain in your gut, unless you have bloating in the gut, bloats out.
So you don't even know that it's there.
So women might say, I have a yeast infection, because I can feel it, et cetera.
But definitely they have gut issues too.
So you have to get these probiotics everywhere that you possibly can, so I say in every oracle
that you possibly can.
So doing a probiotic in them can be very helpful.
Yes.
Again, we recommend high concentration.
Typically the research on probiotic animals, you want close to 1,200 billion organisms.
So that's a lot.
So how are you going to get that concentration?
That's where VSL is very high.
It's per by prescription only.
But still doing any amount of probiotics in them is still going to be beneficial.
They try to retain that about 30 minutes.
Does fasting help the gut?
So is there benefit in fasting?
My view is yes, there is.
Long fasting, there could be other issues with that.
But if you're fasting once a week or one day a week or two days every two weeks there could
be benefit to that, giving the gut a rest, yes, it could be very beneficial.
And the last that nobody wants to talk about that you have to do to help heal the gut is
fecal transplants.
Anybody ever heard about that?
Yes.
Okay, very good.
This must be an informed congregation here.
So fecal transplants when you're taking feces from a healthy individual, you're typically
blending that, watering that down, and you're using that in your animal.
So it's really gross.
If you can get past the gross factor, you can save people's lives literally.
So we have a number of patients doing fecal transplants, very healthy, yes.
So how do you find a healthy donor?
Right, so in our office we run stool tests on them, and we test them.
So we want them free of parasites, and the product is an issue.
Well, you're going to find a healthy donor, typically the donor is going to be from your
family member.
It's not like you're going to knock on your neighbor's door and ask them for a donation.
So it does get to be a little touchy subject there, right?
So if you talk to most people about this, it's pretty gross.
But when you're dealing with somebody's life or death, when you have an ulcerative colitis patient
that has mucus runny stools 20 times a day, you can't even leave home when their life
has been completely destroyed, and they're this close to having their colon removed, and
then they start thinking, well, maybe I should do this.
So you're dealing with a colon cancer patient that has got three weeks to live that maybe
I'll think about doing this.
This is worth trying.
So that does lead back to how sick is the person or they will need to do what is going to be
the best thing for them.
Typically you're trying to get about a quart of fluid.
So that is part stool, part water, your water either down, so it could go through the
element too.
Now, understanding the connection between the gut and the braid is helpful too.
I should have brought copy of some of the way books out up here, but our latest book entitled
Your Crazy.
Did you see it out there?
It's a dark blue cover.
Talks a little bit about the connection between the gut and the braid and how important it
is for the braid.
Another thing that we won't talk about so much today is that patients wonder what we're
doing when we're doing braid-based test data on them and neurological, functional neurological
test data on them, when they don't have a braid problem, I have colon cancer.
So now I can understand the gut thing with my colon cancer, why are we doing some braid
stuff when I have colon cancer?
Your braid controls the healing of everything.
So if you have unhealthy connections in your braid, it's going to affect your gut and
they go both ways.
You've heard of the gluteumorphine receptors in the gut that fire directly to the braid.
Your braid and your gut is so controlled.
It's been said that your gut controls about 90% of your immune response.
So there's a lot of truth to that, so it's very important to heal your gut.
So even if you don't have any gut issues and you're dealing with live issues, it's so
important to heal the gut because most live patients have live spyroketes that across
the blood braid barrier.
It is affecting mood swings and unclear thinking and seems like early dementia symptoms and
healing the gut could be just amazing for that.
So we've even had MS patients do fecal transplant work.
We've had multiple cases of this not just in our clinic but in other clinics that do similar
work that their MS symptoms have completely disappeared after fecal transplant.
So healing the gut turns off a whole bunch of different receptors that affect the brain.
Does that make sense?
So those other nutrients who went too far know.
Those other nutrients are in some different products that we also use and we support.
But again, you can't heal the gut just through nutrients.
You have to change the diet.